[Music]
My name is Rick Bllock. I'm from
Agentuity and uh that you're all wearing
the the logo around your necks. So stop
by our booth, please. But uh today I
want to talk about um conquering agent
chaos. But really I'm talking about
deployment running and deploying agents.
Um and just to give you an example, I
was uh I was at University of Florida.
I'm from South Florida and I was at
University of Florida about a month and
a half ago and I was talking to a bunch
of professors and their students on
projects that they were deploying.
Almost all of them were working on some
type of agents in their class projects
and uh I asked all of them what was the
number one problem. And they all said
including the professors deploying
agents and u they sim similar problems
that I I had before we we started agent
which was like you build this thing you
deployed on serverless in their case
they were using AWS and lambda and then
they you know timeouts right oh my agent
runs for 15 minutes or my agent runs for
30 minutes we have an internal agent at
agent 2 that runs for 40 minutes a day
something like that so they were running
into that and then uh they weren't
allowed to use VMs or EC2 for their
projects So for obvious reasons you want
a bunch of students running EC2s and um
a bunch of other things are running into
the gateway issues you know wiring up
agents talking to agents and things like
that. So it's very very common thing and
the other one is you know the whole web
is built like for a stateless type
concept right agents are not stateless
necessarily they're stateful in a lot of
cases um and so those are the deployment
headaches that I was hearing over and
over with the students and that mapped
to problem I had about a year ago
building a qualitative research agent
set of agents same thing I built it on
serverless not thinking and then I
realized ah crap I got to rearchitect
this whole thing because it's doing
synthesis and it takes a while very
common um headaches. Has has anybody
experienced that headache before. I'm
curious. Yeah. Deploying agents. So that
led us to talk about like well what do
what do agents need to be successful? So
they need to they need to run as long as
they need to run um and they need to be
able to pause and stop and resume. They
also have decoupled from your code. They
need to have different inputs and
outputs and um actually multiple various
ones. Right. We I I think we understand
that hopefully. And then I put this up
here. Introspection, self-observability,
and self-reflection. They need those
two. Um, and we have that in the
product. We have like hotel tracing
things. Hopefully, you've all seen that
some of those types of things where
you're doing introspection and and
traces across. But I put
self-observability and self-reflection
here because this is important. So the
the the observability things that we're
used to are human based where we see
like these traces and spans
and um the agents need to understand
that as well. There's a there's a
there's a difference there. There's a
nuance difference there. Of course it
needs memory. It needs to get better
evolution code execution. So that's what
agents need to be successful. And so
when I was again talking to those UF
students personal experience um we need
those things and that's what we started
to build at agentuity. So, I just want
to give you a demo. I'm trying to
decide. Should I do a live demo or
should I do the the slides just in case?
I don't know.
Live. Everybody says live. You all just
want to watch the train wreck.
All right, we'll we'll try it live. So,
I'll Wow.
Live. Wow. All right, we'll do that. So,
um I'm gonna Let's do this. Let's do
this. Let's blow this baby up. Can you
see this? Okay. Yeah. All right. Good. I
was told I had to do it in light mode
because that's what you do. So, um, all
right. So, we have a CLI. So, if you're
going to start, you run agent create to
create a project. Um, when you run it,
drum roll. Okay. In this case, I'm
logged into a bunch of organizations.
So, I'm going to do our agentity uh demo
one. We have three runtimes that we
support. Bun, Python with UV. You notice
we we put UV. We're trying to bias
people towards UV. Please don't use pip.
Um, and then no.js, of course. So, those
are our three runtimes. I'm going to
pick bun.
And then, uh, you can pick several
templates, um, as a starting place. Now,
we're we're a framework agnostic. You
notice there's MRA here. Monstra is
pretty good if you're going down the
TypeScript route. Um, I'm I'm going to
pick Verscell AI SDK and Grock. I a lot
of our stuff internally, we have 50
agents or so, and they're we don't use
framework. Um, but we're framework
agnostic. So you can bring crew AI and
then deploy another one in lang chain,
another one in paidantic and then versel
and then they can all talk to each
other. Um internal networking talk to
each other and that kind of thing. We'll
show you that here in a minute.
Trying to leave enough time so we can
have questions and answers. So I'm going
to pick Verscell AIK with Grock.
Honestly, it's my favorite combo with
bun because of the speed. It's amazing.
Um and then I'm going to name a project.
Let's just call that project hello. A
project is a grouping of agents. It's
also um you can think of as like a oneto
one to a repo because you can hook it up
to GitHub. An agent you get multiple
agents in a project. You get your
default one here. So let's just call
this agent one. Hello. Uh very creative
name. Now one of the things we give you
agents are a first class citizen. Again
back to deployment problems. Agents are
a first class citizen infra
infrastructure citizen um in agentuity.
So that means we handle all the routing
and all that to that agent and you can
decide how you want to protect it. So
you can protect it via the whole
project. Each agent in your project can
have an API key. I'm going to do none
right now because it's a demo.
There's more to that, but um I'll skip
over that right now. Then you can hook
it up to GitHub. Uh so then if you merge
main, it'll automatically deploy your
project. And that's it. So then we
create this. I'll show you the code here
in a second. I'm going to show you dev
mode real quick and then I'll we'll do
the code. All right. So rocking on. So
let's do project hello.
And before I show you the code,
we have now this versel AI SDK bun, you
know, grock template, right? So we have
this command that you can run any of
your agents with agent2 dev. If you have
multiple projects, you can run them and
then they'll they'll have ports assigned
to them. And so now we're running this
locally as you would expect. Very what
you're used to, I'm sure. But um one of
the things I want I want to show you is
so this is the this routing to the
agent. We only have one agent. So that's
the that's the agent ID. Well, we have
this public routing. So we do tunneling
for you. So if you wanted to hit it
through another service or something
while you're deving, you can do this uh
publicly, too. All right, but let me
just show you the dev mode real quick.
So um click this
is Oh, of course I got logged out.
who expired the token? Um, okay. So, um,
we give you like this kind of simulator
for your agent. Some agents don't take
just text, right? So, you can you can
pick JSON, HTML, you can PDFs. Um,
actually we do emails and things like
that, too. That's not in this dev mode.
But this is where you can interact with
your agent, test it out, and then when
you do that, like I'm just going to run
it a few times. What? I'm sorry.
Somebody say something. Oh, okay. Um,
when you do that, you can get your logs.
Of course, you can see in the terminal,
too. Um, you can in inspect the logs,
get more information, and then the
sessions are back to the remember the
observability thing. So, we have the
human version of this here where you can
look and you can see like, oh, this hit
the this hit our AI gateway, which we
have an AI gateway, so you don't have to
set up keys for any of these models or
any of these services. And you can get
the cost for that call, um, what the
prompt was, what the response was, and
all that. And this works in production,
too. It's the it's a mirror image of
production. So, that's the dev mode. I
don't want to spend too much time on it
because we don't have much time, but
that's So, put a pin in that. Now, I'm
going to kill that. And you're like,
"Well, Rick, what does the code look
like?" And we're trying not to be too
opinionated here, but we do have a few
conventions. Um,
let's do that. Let's do that. Um, so
really the conventions we have in a
project are you have a YAML file,
surprise, and um that's to help
configure your agent when it's deployed.
And then um there's an agents folder.
Python it it works the same way. And um
you have an entry point. And so this is
this is the simple simple template that
we we created here. And the entry point
in in this case in in JavaScript would
be um you export a default function and
that's your request handler. If you guys
have used Nex.js or you've used K
natives or whatever, everybody should be
familiar with that hopefully. But what
we do is we handle all that routing that
comes in to your agent and we put it on
that request object. And so that that
could be an email. You can add email to
your agent. You can add a phone number
to your agent. You can uh send a JSON, a
PDF, whatever. We have all those things
that we route to it. You can stream it.
Um and then also you have you have
things that are like first kind of first
class citizens like ctx get agent and
then that and then you can pass in an ID
or a name. So we have another agent.
Maybe it's a pyantic agent over here.
and we can actually get it. We'll get an
ephemeral token so it's allowed to talk
to it for as long as it runs and then
you can execute it, send it back, you
can stream it back. There's bunch of
different things you can do here. Um,
and so that's on this context object. So
there's I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on this right now, but there's a
there's a lot of like infrastructure we
give you in this really simple handler.
Um, uh, which is pretty cool. All right,
and that's it. That's the only
convention. So again, like you can
imagine if you're using Monstra and we
have a bunch of examples and templates
that you can go look you're you create
Monstra template or models the way you
you you would normally do it and you can
drop them in right here. Same thing in
Python. Um there's a run function in
Python and that's what you have to
declare and then you can drop in a crew
or a couple crews and then have it call
paidantic 2 and another agent. Um and
that's it. That's that's that's the code
in a nutshell. Now let's deploy it
really quick. YOLO.
All right. And it should it the
internet's fast. It should upload pretty
quick there. Boom. All right. So, we
took we took that agent, we wrapped it
in a container, a specialized container.
That's in this case, it's a bun runtime.
And now it's live. So, if I if I click
on that and jump to it,
you can see um this is when it was
deployed. There's our little happy bun.
And um let me show you something really
quick that you haven't seen yet. So in a
project again you have multiple agents.
I only have one agent that you saw me
create and then this is where you can
get you can get cost breakdown by
project by agent by run. You saw the
session spans. So we we try to surface
that up in all different ways to help
understand how much an agent is costing.
But this is where remember when I said
you can decouple inputs and outputs from
your agent if you want to. And this is
where I can hit plus here and I can say,
"Hey, I want to give my agent an email."
I hit save. And now I can email my
agent. So there's the email address
right there. And I can do that with SMS.
Um, I can do that with APIs. I can do a
cron job, wakes up, does a bunch of
things. Um, and that's inputs and
outputs. So it's a nice way to build an
agent and then if somebody wants to use
it, they can hit deploy now from your
GitHub repo, drop it in like, okay, let
me wire this email up. Let me wire this
up. Let me lie later. We're going to get
Slack and Discord and all that stuff
too. Um, so that's inputs and outputs.
Um, actually, let me just go ahead and
try to hit this right here. So, this is
our Remember, we didn't secure it, so
it's public. So, actually, if you took a
picture and hit this, it probably would
work. Don't do that. Um,
let's just I don't know if this is going
to work. Hello.
All right. So, I I hit the web hook. It
created this session. There's the
session ID. Now it's the age is off
running and I should start getting logs
here. Got three minutes.
There it is. Oh, it's an error because I
probably Oh, I Okay, so this is in your
YAML file. You can change the uh the
memory and I I need to change the memory
footprint for this. So, it didn't run.
It's like nope. That's something we're
working on, too. So, in a nutshell, that
is that's what you get. Of course, you
can wire up some integrations and and uh
actually I think I just lost internet.
Okay, there we go. There we go. You can
wire up some integrations, GitHub, and a
bunch of other stuff that's coming. So
um to to kind of wrap up this is this
was like the thing that we wanted to
build not just for everybody but for us
because we wanted to we have now 50 60
agents internally built on this and it's
like finally we're getting really good
velocity and I'm really excited about so
this is our first product in our agent
native cloud suite that we plan on
working on um this summer we're working
on um infrastructure agents that watch
our logs and uh surface things that are
coming up for for um for developers and
us and uh we kind of we were joking last
night we should call it agent duty not
pager duty like the agent's going to do
that so
right exactly so yeah so there's bunch
of stuff coming but that's where we're
at right now stop by the booth um we got
one minute and 50 seconds so if there's
any questions we got about a minute and
50 seconds any any questions
jokes anecdotes
try to leave just enough yes one thing
that I've been hearing about recently is
the idea of adding tools into
um
tokens. Is that something you think
about?
Yeah. Uhhuh. And it I mean Yeah, for
sure. Yeah. Um
that now there's a for us like from a
product perspective there's a thing we
always ask ourselves which is what does
an agent need to be successful and and
some of that is what like we want to
offer that as a services layer from an
infrastructure services perspective
where a lot of that stuff you just get
out of the box and then you can hook it
up to a versel AI SDK tool thing or you
can hook it up to something else like we
want to do some of those kind of service
level things but I mean like on a
tactical level. Yeah, I I think it's I
mean I need them actually for a CRM
agent that we're working on. So, yeah.
Cool. All right. Thanks everybody for
coming.
[Music]